we are taking calls from you without you
i'm a guy in a room with a mic talking
to the wall and it's sad it's very sad
but with you guys here this is actually
a show we take calls via discord at
slash
davidpakman.com
and it is a
it's a great thing it's really a great
thing let's go next
where are we going next let's go to
houston and speak to jorge jorge you're
on the air
hi david uh i'm originally from mexico
but i've lived uh here in houston my
whole life okay and we have a very
trump-like president right now in mexico
very narcissistic
authoritarian
his last
sort of uh hint that he was
going towards this very authoritarian
aisle was uh he hinted that
he liked putin and he wasn't going to do
any sanctions
so
all this all this is uh was sort of
he sort of came to popularity around
trump also what do you think it is uh
that people are so attracted to these
narcissistic clown authoritarian types
so i don't know that much about uh the
authoritarian piece i mean i i i know
about the sort of uh narcissism
and i but but it is at least ostensibly
a left-leaning coalition in mexico right
now i mean i guess what you're telling
me is that in practice it's
authoritarian
yeah so he
he's sort of taken over the military and
they're doing
uh
sort of his policing
he's trying to strengthen the military
to
to
to sort of solidify his power another
play he wanted was amend the
constitution so he could stay in power
for another term thankfully uh he didn't
win the congress so he can't really do
that yeah but it's those sort of things
and so you're wondering what it is about
these authoritarians that is appealing
to people
yeah yeah i think it's it's it's sort of
basic uh crowd psychology to some degree
and the idea that some some idea some
ideologies are easier to sell than
others and so like for example populism
populism is not a set of policies as
i've talked about before populism is
really a rhetoric and that so when we
say left-wing populism or right-wing
populism we're not really talking about
policies some people will say there's no
such thing as right-wing populism right
well it's just it's rhetoric it's
populist rhetoric from right-wingers or
left-wingers and populist rhetoric is
very appealing to a lot of people the
devil is in what policies do you follow
it up with you see populist rhetoric
from the left and it's like bernie
policies and then you see populist
rhetoric from the right and it's like
yeah and the problem the reason for all
our problems is you know brown people
from mexico and so we've got to just
stop them from coming in so i think that
the
trump types putin types etc there's a
large population base that loves the
strongman of sorts and it's just
appealing no matter what policy is
behind it and that that's why it works
so often
yeah that makes sense it just i found it
very weird how trump's policies are very
different from sort of these liberal
policies coming from mexico yes
they're they're the same type of person
you know the narcissist
wanting to take control manipulating
people lying all the time
and it just seemed people were really
attracted to that 100 and unfortunately
sometimes it can work for a long time it
does it doesn't obviously fail uh and
i mean listen we're seeing it we're
seeing it around the world it's not
there's many places around the world
where we're seeing exactly that and it's
horrifying
yeah very scary thank you david all
right thank you for the call very much
appreciate it let's go next to dave from
brooklyn dave you're on the air
hello can hear me yes i can
um i'm a long-time listener this is my
second time i've called but i'm just
calling because i wanted to get a little
more perspective on you from you because
you've been talking a lot recently about
the issues that we're facing as a left
and after listening to the the state of
union address last night i feel like it
was so all over the place with so little
focus it just kind of reinforced the
message that you've been saying for a
while that as the
left and progressive we have no focus
and i was wondering what if you were in
charge what are like the two three maybe
four things you would
focus in on and get done to start
bringing
people back into
are
are fold politically yeah that's a good
question listen is there a tv in the
background because it's very tough to
hear you over it
uh no worries i can disconnect and just
uh listen to the answer oh okay all
right yeah so listen if i i think that
um yes one of the one of my critiques of
the state of the union was that it
really was all over the place with like
no transitions whatsoever joe biden was
going from
uh we're going to control prices when
businesses are charging too much without
saying why to we're going to change
taxes and we're stopping flights from
russia and we're going to beat cancer
and you know all these it was it was
very much all over the place which is
okay it's okay for a state of the union
to lay out a big vision that includes a
lot of different things i if it were me
right now
saying the left has to be focused i
would try to narrow things a little bit
and say okay we've got to pick
one or two things on the economic
justice front so there's all these
different things there's minimum wage
totally changing the tax code uh
undoing tax loopholes
student loan debt all these different
things i would i would say like let's
pick two specific things on the economic
side that we're going to do
let's come up with a pro-business plan
on the environment and really just lay
out again one or two things
here's the lowest hanging fruit on how
we can both
support business
and
help the environment and
whether it's a green energy focus or
whatever find like two things there
and then
thirdly
make some kind of clear
statement
um to some degree i i i hope
about the state of democracy
and simplify what really needs to be
done to take the narrative back that
from the those on the right who are now
saying elections just can't be trusted
and anybody could have really won you'd
have no way of knowing that's very
dangerous and demoralizing it also
happens to be untrue so i think that's
what i would do i would say number one
let's get just a simple message out
there to undo all of the stuff that's
been opened up about the big lie and
trump really won and all that we got to
put a stop to that and get people really
thinking uh
clearly about what's actually going on
number two let's do something that feels
good about the environment but that also
is very clearly not going to be back
quote bad for business the way many on
the right say anything we do to deal
with climate change is going to be
terrible for business no it doesn't have
to be that way and then again on
something economic just pick say we're
going to make these three changes to the
tax code and we'll pay 10 grand of
student debt that's it and then you you
have to restrict the conversation and
this will upset some people some people
say no but you're not including minimum
wage in that or you didn't include this
i i get it
you can't ever do anything so why even
pretend like you can let's really narrow
the message and say here's what what
we're going to get done that would be my
suggestion